We’re gonna have to do the shuffle again.
Shuff-shuffle again. Do the shuffle again.
2019, it’s the shuffle remix.
Reminisce cause we missed '85, '86.
Leader of the offense.
The defense is so fresh,
I’m in the NFL
and I just learned how to throw left.
I can scramble, I can run
I can throw touch passes.
And I’m livin’ in the city with the
most mustaches.
Nagy can nag me
but don’t call me Mitch.
And my name ain’t Jay Cutler
so don’t call me-
Whatever?!
Go to Club Dub.
We all got up in
bringing back '86 with the shuffle again.
Last name Cohen
so I get a bar mitzvah.
And I got a new sweater
so I’m dressed like Mike Ditka.
And we don’t mean this is a mean way
Cheese-eating hillbillies
all live in Green Bay.
D-D-D-DEFENSE!!!!!!!
Check the movement
monsters of the midway
defense superhuman.
Never losin’, and we get stupid
stupid like when I was traded by Gruden.
Turn a player to a hater
when I hit a player
QB incinerator
imitator of refrigerator.
HICKS.
FULLER.
JACKSON.
Defense killin’.
And I’m worth 2 first-round draft picks
and $141 million.
In 2019, take it back to '86.
When we win, we’ll do
the Super Bowl Shuffle remix.
Hopefully.